[Music]
hi dalton how are you
good dave how are you doing better than
i deserve man what's up in your world
well i was just calling i have a couple
questions i've been listening to a few
years podcast and i just figured why not
call in so cool i am 22 years old and
i've been working for the well since i
was 19. i went to school for welding
and i've been traveling the tri-state
area where i live for the past almost
three years
well sometimes nineteen so two three
years and uh i've
saved up almost ninety thousand dollars
wow wow
good for you
yeah what kind of money are you making a
year as a welder
um close to if i work i work outages and
sometimes it's uh iffy like you work a
few months here a few months there but
on an average of average from 80 to 100
000 a year good for you well done the
trades pay well you're working a lot of
hours it's hard work but you're making
good money right yes
yes yeah yeah i mean when you're when
you're on you're working that's that's
tough work but uh
and so you're working power stuff huh
yeah nuclear mostly i've worked in uh
live nuclear plants and building nuclear
plants
okay wow wow
yeah you're you're really building a
resume there that's pretty impressive
good and you got 85 000 and are you
living at home or are you are you living
in a camper i mean what are you doing
i recently just bought a camper about a
month ago and before that i was living
with a high school friend that went to
welding school with in his camper and
then before that i had rented an
apartment which was one of my worst
mistakes but you live in yarn yeah
because you're never there
exactly yeah exactly
a lot more i could have paid for a
camper for when i paid rent in that
apartment yeah so you so you're going to
suv i mean as you're going to winnebago
it around or whatever while you uh
whatever the brand is while you
run this circuit for a while at this
stage of your life how long do you think
you're going to live that life
well that's what i was asking i was
recently
getting some advice because i was
talking to
a person i knew that has only owned the
business and they told me well if you
don't want to travel all the time why
don't you
buy like a service truck and open your
own business and so i was just going to
ask you
what you thought about that idea or how
much money you think you would have to
have saved up to start your own business
as a welding business enough to buy the
supplies
in the truck
okay you can outfit this truck for 50
grand right
yes
yeah yeah because you don't want a fancy
truck it's going to be hauling a bunch
of junk around
yeah yeah i mean it is it's welding
equipment it's your trade but it's not
this is not a you don't need you don't
need a
something from a chevy commercial i mean
this is this is a work truck right
exactly and so uh i love that idea so
what i would tell you if you're my 22
year old son is that running a business
is different than running an arc welder
okay so you have the skills to be a
welder you do not have the skills yet to
run a business
okay and much like you had to learn how
to weld you're going to learn how to run
a business
and so you've got to start thinking
about what it takes to operate a
business
not just perform the task
okay so i mean buying a truck and
getting the welding gear yeah and can
you do the job once you've got the job
yeah but you have to price it you have
to collect it you have to pay your taxes
you have to get new customers you have
to take care of the existing customers
and now you're running a business
yes and so i you know and it is at least
as difficult to run a business with a
service truck like that as it is to weld
the other thing dalton is and don't let
that discourage you because the
day-to-day will still be the welding
work
your day-to-day will still be doing the
work you know how to do and you love how
to do but there will be a learning curve
where you figure out how are you going
to price this how are you going to
manage the money how are you going to
interact with customers with clients and
and
and even points of contact like the
really tactical stuff that you probably
don't deal with day to day and you
haven't even thought about in terms of
your business some of this is as simple
as talking to someone who's running a
business as as doing a google search as
just putting some of your notes and
ideas on paper start to just
let this idea simmer in your mind and
capture your thoughts in a notebook or
something really basic this does not
have to be sophisticated and it doesn't
have to overwhelm you
once you get through this learning curve
of learning some of the basic business
setup and the basic business operations
you will spend the vast majority of your
time 80 to 90 of your time doing the
welding work especially out of the gate
because that's that's you know in the
initial stages that you just own your
job that's what you're doing but you do
need to just think about some of these
things and and learn some of these
things and uh and if you start doing
that you could
make even more money doing this i want
you to find a 35 year old guy that's
running a truck
and doing welding
and making a good living
and i want you to go take a day or two
or next time you've got some down time i
want you to go spend three days with him
take your camper okay take your camper
go hang out in that city where he could
be two cities over five cities over i
don't care maybe he's over at dallas
you're mobile you run over there from it
you run over there from atlanta spend
two or three days with him and i want
you to go to school not on welding
on running a business
how do you run a business what did you
not know what do i need to know how do
you do your pricing where do your
customers come from and i want you to
take like some yellow pads or an ipad or
something i want you to fill up thousand
thousand thousand files of the answers
of an actual practitioner in that world
and so you know when you first learn to
weld they showed you that someone showed
you by welding
you watched them weld
right
yes they're exactly very first class and
then you tried it
and then they helped you by letting you
watch the then you watched it again and
then you tried it again until finally
that thing would quit sticking and it
would actually create an arc right
exactly and um so
well maybe you're doing acetylene i
don't know but um but anyway
the metaphor still stands so
yeah you go
you go study someone else and then you
do it and then you study someone else
and then you do it and then you study
someone else and and your first step is
to get the business up and running and
then your next step is to grow the
business to where it's not
where you own more than just your job
your first goal in business is at least
own your own job
and when you if you don't work if you
don't go to work you don't get paid
that's owning your own job right but if
you got five people working for your
welding and six trucks out there
now you own a business that if you don't
work one day they all still work
and that's that's growing into the next
level but i don't want to go too fast
here you're 22 you got plenty of time
yes i would buy a service truck and yes
i would go into business if you have
that desire but go study business from a
couple people i'm going to give you a
copy of our number one best-selling book
uh entree leadership which is how it's
our playbook on how we started this
business and how we ran it and run it
and it'll give you some good guidelines
on how to get there dalton i want to
give you a couple questions too to ask
these people that you're going to study
and shadow and learn from one ask them
what did you learn the hard way
another uh another way to ask it is what
did you wish you knew when you got
started
and another thing to ask them are what
are the biggest trip ups i should look
out for like customers or problems or
things that man that that just you know
might might be a potential landmine that
you don't even know how can you learn
about that before you get into it ask
some of those questions to get some of
those learnings without you having to
learn the hard way yourself and and
they'll tell you uh they'll they'll show
you and you can you can avoid that going
out you know out of the gate i love that
what a great young guy mm-hmm that's
cool we've talked about a great couple
of 22 year olds in the last couple of
hours they're doing pretty impressive
stuff yeah so there's hope america
there's hope the next generation coming
on there's some good ones in the bunch
there's a bunch of good ones in the
bunch and um no bunch has all good ones
the bunch has all bad ones but this
bunch has got some really good ones
that's pretty cool and the trades uh
well with this uh epic student loan
debacle yeah that we have uh in higher
education the trades are coming back on
with a gale force wins everybody's
moving into the trades i mean when you
can with a high school education at 22
for the last four years while his
friends were in college making nothing
he's made a hundred thousand dollars a
year
he's doing okay he's 400 grand ahead
before they got started
very interesting